this is a rather theoretical exercise
that has two purposes one is to verify
that the notion of convergence in
probability is quite natural and that it
has properties similar to the notion of
convergence of sequences and the second
purpose is to get a little bit of
practice with the formal definition of
convergence in probability so what is
the statement saying it says that if we
have a sequence of random variables two
that converges to a certain number a and
this basically means that when n is
large the distribution is highly
concentrated around a and if we have
another sequence of random variables
that converge to a certain number B
which means that the probability
distribution of Y n is heavily
concentrated around B in that case then
the probability distribution of the sum
of the two random variables is heavily
concentrated in the vicinity of a plus B
so what are we saying if xn is very
close to a with high probability and yn
is very close to B with high probability
then the sum will also be close to a
plus B with high probability this is the
intuitive content of the statements now
we want to establish this formally
before establishing this statement
however it will be good practice to
verify a property of this type for the
ordinary convergence of sequences of
numbers not random variables so let us
do that what we want to show is that if
a sequence of numbers a n converges to
some number a and another sequence
converges to some number B we want to
show that in that case a n plus BN
converges to the sum of a plus B and we
want to do this formally so let us start
with the definition of convergence what
does it mean that a n converges to a
it means that if I fix some positive
epsilon then there exists some number or
some time such that if we consider some
n bigger than n 0 then a yin is close to
a in the sense that this difference is
less than Epsilon now this is true for
any positive epsilon so if instead of
epsilon I take epsilon over 2 this will
also be true eventually after some time
we will have the property that a n minus
a is less than epsilon over 2 similarly
if BN converges to B then we will have
the property that there exists some time
let's call it n 0 prime such that if n
is bigger than that particular time then
BN minus B is going to be less than
epsilon over 2 okay so after time and 0
and after time and 0 crime these two
inequalities will be true so if we wait
long enough so that both of these
inequalities are true that is if n is
bigger than the maximum of n 0 and n 0
prime then we will have the following we
will have that aen
plus BN minus a minus B which by an
elementary inequality is less than or
equal to a and minus a plus BN minus B
okay where does this inequality coming
from this is a general inequality about
absolute values if I give you two
numbers the absolute value of x plus y
is always less than or equal to the sum
of the absolute values so we're using
this inequality where X is a and minus a
and Y is BN minus B so we have this
inequality but when time is big enough a
n minus a is less than epsilon over 2 BN
minus B is also less than epsilon over 2
and putting everything together
this is Epsilon so what we have we shown
that if a and converges to a and BN
converges to B so that all these
relations holds then if time n is large
enough then the difference between this
number and that number is going to be
less than Epsilon
and this is true for every positive
epsilon but that's just the definition
of convergence of this quantity to that
quantity and this is the proof of this
elementary relation about convergence of
numbers now let us turn to convergence
of random variables we fix some epsilon
that's positive in order to show
convergence in probability we want to
look at this difference
and look at the probability that this
difference is bigger than epsilon in
magnitude and we want to show that this
quantity converges to zero if it does
then we will have established
convergence in probability because
that's just the definition okay now this
is the event that the sum of the random
variables is close to a plus B and we
want to use the fact that X and is
closed way and yn is close to B so this
is the event that let's write it in a
somewhat different way it's the
probability of the event that xn minus a
plus y n minus B is bigger than epsilon
in magnitudes now for a sum of two
numbers to be bigger than epsilon in
magnitude it has to be the case that
either one of them is larger than
epsilon over two or the other number is
bigger in magnitude than epsilon over
two so if this event happens this event
must also happen this means that this
event is a subset of this event this is
a smaller one if this happens then this
one happens so since it's a smaller
event it means that its probability is
less than or equal to the probability of
that event now we use the Union bound
the probability that something happens
or something else is happening is less
than or equal to the sum of their
probabilities
and now since xn converges to a in
probability then by definition we know
that this quantity converges to 0 as n
goes to infinity similarly since yn
converges to be in probability this
quantity converges to 0 as n goes to
infinity this is a sequence of numbers
that converges to 0 this is another
sequence of numbers that converges to 0
therefore the sum of these two sequences
also converges to 0 in essence here were
applying what we established earlier
about convergence of numbers if a
sequence converges to 0 and another
sequence converges to 0 then the sum of
these sequences also converges to 0 as n
goes to infinity but this is exactly
what we need to show in order to
establish convergence in probability of
xn plus yn we have shown that if I fix
any epsilon positive no matter how small
the probability that I am more than
epsilon away that probability that xn
plus yn is more than epsilon away from
the supposed target or the limit this
probability must go to 0 and that's
exactly what we established here and
this completes the derivation